je t'aime est une phrase qui tient une
place bien particulière de notre culture
et dans nos vies en général c'est une
phrase à la fois très importante et
super ambivalente tout le monde
reconnaît que sa prononciation avait
quelque chose d'important on ne dit pas
je t'aime à la légère ça semble souvent
réservé à une relation amoureuse qui
prend mon propre vécu comme exemple j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya souvent eu dans
les relations amicales des détours
sémantique des périphrases que ce soit
avec mes amis fille ou garçon genre tu
compte beaucoup pour moi j'ai la chance
de t'avoir je n'ai jamais eu une
meilleure amie je ne sais pas ce que je
ferais sans toi mais je t'aime c'est
assez rare au fond il arrive qu'on dise
bien sûr mais c'est moins 5 on tour
nable que dans les relations amoureuses
par exemple on ne s'inquiète pas parce
qu'un ami nous a pas encore dit je
t'aime dans les relations amoureuses ces
centrales on peut se demander quand
est-ce que c'est le bon moment pour le
dire on peut avoir peur d'être le
premier à dire on peut être impatient de
le dire on peut avoir envie de le dire
toute la journée et on voit bien que
cette phrase est liée à une impression
un sentiment une sensation très forte
dont on ne peut douter mais qu'est ce
que ça veut dire qu'est-ce que je t'aime
veut dire ce que je trouve fou c'est
qu'on puisse donner tant d'importance à
une phrase aussi flou aussi peu défini
on entend quelqu'un nous dire je t'aime
et on est ému alors qu'en fait il n'y a
pas moyen de savoir si pour la personne
qui nous dit ça signifie la même chose
que pour nous quand on dit si c'est lié
aux mêmes impressions sentiment
sensations on pourrait être tenté de se
demander ce que la phrase je t'aime vos
sens le comportement qui doit
l'accompagner mais justement quel est ce
comportement quelle est l'attitude qui
nous paraît exprimer ce je t'aime
j'imagine que c'est une question à la
fois toute simple et super centrale si
on veut penser nos relations il y a des
gens qui sont tout à fait sincère quand
il dit je t'aime et qui ont pourtant un
comportement super toxique pour la
personne qui disent aimer possessif
manipulateur humiliant alors on a envie
de dire que c'est pas de l'amour mais
donc ce serait quoi aimer quelqu'un ça
paraît évident que ça suppose du respect
de la netteté de l'empathie de l'ecoute
du soutien mettons toujours à la hauteur
de l'amour compte il est prouvé pour
l'autre ce qui nous indique que l'amour
n'est rien d'autre que la joie qui
accompagne l'idée d'une cause extérieure
à partir de cette définition j'ai envie
de dire qui a ému une chose
c'est quand l'idée de son existence nous
rend heureux quand on est content qu'une
chose existe tout simplement c'est qu'on
lève mais il faudrait immédiatement
précisé c'est l'idée de son existence
libre et non de son existence pour nous
imaginons qu'on dise j'aime le pain en
fait ce qu'on veut dire c'est j'aime le
pain parce que l'idée que le pain existe
et que je peux donc en manger me rend
heureux en fait là non ce n'est pas le
pain que j'aime ce que j'aime c'est
manger du pain c'est qu'on aime ça
change tout parce que là l'amour est
tourné vers mon expérience vers mon
plaisir
si antoine dit je t'aime à benjamin si
bérénice dit je t'aime à cassandre ça
peut vouloir dire j'aime passer du temps
avec toi j'aime d'avoir à moi j'aime
quand tu m'écoutes j'aime quand tu me
fais rire j'aime quand tu me regardes
c'est différent d'un pur je t'aime dont
le pur je t'aime on est heureux que la
personne existe même libres de nous même
loin de nous même si on ne peut pas en
profiter ça nous rend heureux que notre
existe même si on n'a pas accès à
l'autre même si on ne peut profiter de
sa présence ce qui n'empêche pas qu'on
puisse aussi aimé passer du temps avec
l'autre mais je crois qu'il est
intéressant de prendre conscience de la
tonalité égoïste de ce qu'on veut dire
quand on déclare à l'autre qu'on lève on
pourrait être tenté d'ajouter par
exemple qu aimer quelqu'un c'est vouloir
que cette personne soit heureuse et donc
logiquement il ne peut y avoir de place
pour l'ag l'occident l'amour et c'est
quelqu'un qu'on dit aimer veut nous
quitter pour quelqu'un d'autre on pourra
être triste pour soi parce qu'on ne
pourra plus profiter de sa présence mais
on ne sera pas triste par amour dans
l'amour de l'autre il n'y a pas de place
pour les désirs personnels au contraire
l'amour est libérateur parce qu'il me
libère de moi même parce que dans
l'amour je considère le bonheur de
l'autre comme plus important que le mien
l'amour nous libère de la préoccupation
de soi à bientôt